[Music]
I feel like James Bond are like uh so
I've been drinking a whiskey on the
Rocks okay like gay people bisexual
trans yeah I love everybody you love
everybody yeah I believe in love speech
and you jumped on an old guy yeah
because he he was telling me with your
friends women are insane this is why
women are crazy I'm literally older than
you and you're calling me a baby
right now yeah you woke up an hour ago I
know
well
you want to tame a drug dealer yeah
yeah but what is a red flag with you
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
season one episode two of The Red Pill
Bachelor welcome sneaker
yeah today we're here to help you find
love okay we um I know you want multiple
wives four four yeah so I'm trying to
help you find one of the four maybe two
of the four you know that's very hopeful
we're in London what what's wrong with
London come on
wow
this has infected a lot of their minds
and so they're not really you can train
a woke girl to become wifeable but is it
really worth the effort and time maybe
maybe you'll find a non-woke girl
hopefully hopefully if you have them
then I would be really surprised but I'm
expecting all of them to be extremely
jabbed up mentality you know piercings
non-binary type Behavior that's what is
probably gonna that's what you you know
this is last minute we'll see well um
what do you look for in a wife
I look for
a
well she gotta be she gotta be on jab
okay because I want to have kids I I
look at
a wife that I would want to be the
mother of my children so I'm looking for
motherly qualities I'm looking for I
mean she has to be attractive and she
has to like how attractive like one to
ten
I don't want to I wanted to have a
master race of children okay so she's
got to be I want eight eights in it I'll
take it I'll you can make a seven and
eight you can even make a six and eight
you could start a six and two and eight
how
like the right diet Jim
maybe some others okay so six and up
basically you're you're open to
yeah okay okay six and up six and up I
can make a six and eight seven and up
okay okay what else what else do you
look for
I'm looking for yeah and a
girl that makes sense it's because it's
easy to talk to
um I'm very physical with the women that
I like I like to objectify
oh and is that it what do you that you
triggered yeah no I'm just kidding yeah
we objectify here don't worry of course
I wanna I want to objectify her and also
I want to be able to hold a conversation
with her and I don't want to have to
change my
sense of self
and it's not that hard to I think women
really overestimate like how much work
you don't have to do that much to
pleasing a man is not hard it's not that
hard we're simple cook
you know be good and and when you're in
a private space
and
you know sit there smile and so that if
you do those three things you can get a
man
and what challenges have you had so far
why don't you have four wives already
oh
a lot of time it's the competition that
they want to be the only one so that
part gets in the way they're like I'm
better than the others to be honest I'm
willing to compromise and maybe that's
simping and they're gonna get mad at me
in the comments but if I could find two
two or three you'll go down to two I'll
settle you'll settle I'll settle for two
or three wow that's so nice of you
really yeah I'm a generous guy I'm
willing to compromise for the for the
right ones but yeah I'm looking forward
to this date setting it's a little bit
gonna be uncomfortable for these girls
because you know there's lights and
cameras and stuff like that like the
chairs are facing this way we don't have
any food and I have to just like come up
with whatever she has a bunch of whining
all right let's get into it Pearl all
right I thought I thought you could make
a date out I can make a date I thought
you were the smoothest all right you can
make any situation yeah okay so um we
got to the women today they're really
excited to meet you
um
yeah that's all I can really think of so
I'm excited to meet them so there's
gonna be three rounds today
and um after the first round you'll have
to make some eliminations I know it's
going to be tough
um I know you're gonna have made a lot
of connections but you have to let some
go and then there's gonna be a second
round and then there's one maybe two
winners because you do want four wives
so we're accommodating here all right
thank you yeah anyways guys like the
video let's get the dates let's find
some love
hello Hello nice to meet you nice to
meet you what's your name cicada yeah
I'm sneaker I am nice to meet you is
that your real name it's Hubert right oh
eventually hobby
where are you from wow okay
um I did to Mary personally I don't know
about you oh I like that yeah I like I
do that as well yeah you grew up Muslim
what if the guy that you're dating wants
to have multiple wives
oh god wow what a question
um that's the type of stuff I like
talking about now we're getting
somewhere yeah
um
well I feel like I would I would have to
Well we'd have to have a conversation
about that obviously
um let's have that conversation
okay if you have the means to do it I do
then I I I'm not against it like if you
are going to take care of me and I'm
gonna be fine I'm not gonna be bothered
by that
it's another green flag what if one of
the wives was more attractive to you
more attractive than you in your eyes
I don't really
I don't think like that I just think you
know there's always going to be someone
beautiful out there
are supermodels and you know there's
like all these Instagram girls like
everyone looks beautiful nowadays and
it's like if he's just gonna be carrying
about looks then he's not really the
type of man I want like I'm not looking
for a man who is like superficial like
I'm sure if he married me is because he
loves the person that I am and he really
sees past all of this like I'm not
always going to be like this when we're
married wow you really want do you come
from a big family then I've got a
medium-sized family okay if I would like
a very big family a lot of kids running
around interesting want an army okay and
you want four wives I want four yes
that's a lot I think I think two or
three two or three is realistic a lot
you know Four's a lot of work wow it was
a lot of work you're a busy guy I'm a
busy guy a lot of stuff going on so that
would be
difficult to maintain that sounds like
running a classroom yeah that's why you
can that's why you help like your
favorite wife comes in am I gonna be
your favorite hopefully it's going well
so far you got cheeky okay I like the
way you look okay a lot of green flags
good conversation
you can kind of micromanage yeah the
other wives right so you're the
the assistant manager I'm the CEO okay
and then we got a couple cashiers
I like the sound of this yeah two
cashews and then one janitor okay and
the janitor like she picks up the trash
you know we don't really talk to her
that's crazy because I've always wanted
that that's on my list of requirements
when I get married is that you're the
priority wife okay wait that's the give
me the list of requirements well I've
always wanted some kind of help like I
want my man to be able to get me some
kind of help so like a maid or a
housekeeper or someone oh of course
that's always been on my list that's
that's a given amazing I just have my
mom and my little brother now my father
passed away three years ago okay so it's
like we are super close knit right now
we could work that out yeah my mum
thinks that she's just gonna go
everywhere with me she's like wherever
you go like I used to live in Dubai she
was like I'm coming what the
repeat that I used to live in Dubai calm
down I live there one year
yeah oh no no come on no come on
you don't know you haven't even heard my
story or anything okay this needs a good
explanation I went there for a job I got
offered a really no real estate no I I'm
a TV presenter and journalist so I got
offered a really exciting opportunity
out there because I speak Arabic as well
so they wanted someone who speaks
English and Arabic it was great I went
there everything you know obviously
Dubai they take care of you they give
you free accommodation like the salary
was good how good was the salary
um it was good like it was definitely
more than I'm getting do you have any
side hustles no I didn't no I didn't I
was quite young I was I was like
22 when I went there it's also still
kind of you know young
um
I realized I didn't like it it's not
mentally friendly
um It's Too Fake too superficial for me
and people really lost there and I was
like I need to come hard who's buying a
house I had a friend she was like one of
the top real estate agents in Dubai
she's like this Swedish Barbie looking
girl she's yeah I never knew what she
was doing out there actually I knew what
she was doing out there yeah she was
like always like going on private jets
and like what do you what do you think
that she was doing you think that
someone asked like like in my head I was
like what is she doing really
poop Tano was maybe like the day was
like a five out of ten you know good
Banta
good back and forth I like that she said
that I can have other wives she was not
really all footing about that
um you know Cool vibe
but you know
you know
I didn't I wasn't
there's not enough
you know I don't want to be rude but
there I wanted
I want to be oh
does that you know what I'm saying do
you know you know what I'm saying but it
was good it was good
that's why it's good that she's willing
to for the four wives because then
you know
but she no she was great she was great
she looked great liked her makeup I
um a good person good smile nice girl
right I can't handle weed I'm like
and I just I get a win do you drink
I I do commit Haram and drink yes I know
it's the last day of well second last
day of Ramadan yeah do drink okay so
what's your favorite drink
I like uh going classic right now I'm
feeling classy I'm wearing a nice shirt
I don't know if you see my shoes thank
you these shoes they're cute yeah
they're nice I feel like James Bond are
like uh so I've been drinking a whiskey
on the Rocks okay and sometimes oh it's
so bad there we go I was just like be at
home like just in my birthday soon if
people are there obviously I wear like
my dressing up I like being free like
sometimes just yeah that's not that bad
it's not that bad but like it's like
that's that's normal you like to why
would you want to wear clothes but yeah
I do that and it's true it's just in
alone in your bed or like with other
people in the house no no in my room if
other people in my house I'm not doing
that no way okay yeah because I know
some girls like they'll just they won't
care the walk like hey yeah my best
friend's like that she's too funny I've
gone to her house and she's opened the
door I'm like really she's like yeah I'm
I'm free I'm in my house I'm like okay
do you boo but you're in the house too
so it's a little bit it's a bit weird
but I'm just like nice cool you don't
like that does that bother you because
I'm like oh cool but it doesn't love me
no she's in her own house she's this her
body she can do what she wants with it
so what type of
thoughts and feelings you have when you
see other female breasts
no I don't have any thoughts I've got
I've got my own so
so you don't need you don't need to no
why would I think you don't just wanna
no
no no no you don't just want to like
slap them I have I have enough of mine
so yeah it's really yeah I wouldn't just
go upstairs no okay would you ever do I
I that that's what I want to do when I
see them walking around like yeah I just
want to just hey how you doing buddy hey
nice to see you you know come here oh a
long time no see
you don't do that no you're like hey
babe come here no I didn't sound like
that your voice Got Deep when you said
that did it yeah oh babe it's good no
I've got a nice bum in it
we don't say anything like that say it
again in it why do you say it you've got
a nice bun minute what you're saying it
with an accent
yeah just you know not in it
come here with your bum in it all right
sorry I'm done there's a lot of
Jamaicans in London right
quite a few here can you tell me some of
the slang I love saying one book
ladies I love that you guys are really
good with your homophobia
yeah
in Jamaica they're a bit like you can
still wait for me yeah yeah all of that
but I just think that's the cause of the
lifestyle and how it is out there
they're just a bit like it's a bit much
but if I feel like if they come over
here and live in like in London and see
like gay people it it's not I feel like
it doesn't bother me I don't really mind
but obviously in Jamaica it's a big
thing like
that I know oh so you you like those
people it's not that I I wouldn't say I
don't like I just don't have an issue if
that's what they're into that's what
they're into I'm not going to judge them
just because they're gay or they're
non-binary that's their preference and
that's their lifestyle
non-binary yeah I don't have it's not my
I don't feel like it's right to judge
people it was really stupid about
non-binary
is that actually creates a binary
because non-binary implies that there is
a binary So when you say there's binary
and non-binary that's what that is yeah
a binary it's so stupid it's so they've
created this thing like there's normal
people and there's different people yeah
and so different people like queer
whatever this thing it's and so now
you've made a new one and then what do
you know what's going to happen soon
there's going to be a non-binary for
those non-bind because that's the new
binary yeah yeah and there's going to be
a new Rainbow thing I don't even know
what colors they're going to use we're
married we have a kid yeah we have a
two-year-old son
and I tell you
I want to change my gender and I'm
leaving the marriage hey you yeah I'm
not I'm going to become a a woman I'm
gonna become a woman I'm gonna start
taking estrogen I'm gonna go cut off
this
and you gotta raise the Sun
and there's a minute left but this is
very important part
what are you doing
um to be fair because I married you and
you're my husband I will always support
you I'm your wife now well yeah I would
I would support you in your choice and
what you do because I think that they
are married you because I fell in love
with your energy your Vibe your
personality if you choose to change that
that's you but it wouldn't stop me from
loving you because you were who I loved
on the beginning until now as Sir the
Jamaican girl I like that
she didn't get triggered when I said no
no
to that nonsense that we brought up at
the end that was good that she's willing
to uh look past that she doesn't get
that triggered by something that's
anti-woke she had uh
I thought she knit that shirt because
that was those things were
those things I really wanted to go like
just just in the middle of the day I got
the she said she has the intrusive
thoughts about I wanted to
I just wanted to pounce on it but no she
was good nice nice I was looking in her
eyes trying not to look down I liked her
I would say
um
yeah I'm interested in I want to see see
more of the girls man but the both I
would say absolutely it was like a six
out of 10 days you're a little nervous
but that's good I like when a girl's
nervous and she's cheapest and she's
trying to qualify herself because uh
this is I'm in my element right now I'm
definitely full oh
I love Pride I'm a very proud person you
know no I mean like gay people bisexual
trans yeah I love everybody you love
everybody yeah I believe in love speech
that we should love everyone I
appreciate that yeah I appreciate it are
you one of the are you on the alphabet
maybe what does that mean like you're
being probably on the Queue probably on
the Queue what does that mean queer so
like I'm not for or against anything I'm
just curious like I don't mind
you know that used to be an insult
you're a queer and now so I guess it's
like reclaimed I guess okay you know how
like
the n-word was reclaimed for the black
people I guess it's not the same way at
all but I'm get I'm saying it's like
it's reclaimed in that sense so you're
like I'm not you're the n-word of the
alphabet people no I don't really want
to say no no I meant like the the
derogatory term has been reclaimed are
they I'm pretty sure they still get
upset about that in America that there's
all these yeah they'll beat the dog poop
out of some if a white lady says it
you'll see all these teenagers in
Chicago
really yeah
no no no that's not like here like I
guess if someone calls you queer like
it's not an insult well I'm sorry about
the n-word oh the N what yeah no no no
it's a problem here as well you could
that would yeah no no no it's a problem
here I was talking about the word
so if I say that it's not an insult no
oh you're queer yeah I don't find that
offensive okay queer
so what makes you think that you're a
queue you're cute oh because I'm I'm
open I'm I'm open like if if I fell in
love with a woman so you've had the
reason
yeah off camera yes yeah on camera no
yeah
that's what Q means you're open to it
no Q means I'm open to loving anyone I
guess that's how I view it like I'm open
to loving whoever I want to love like if
if I fall in love with a woman then I
fall in love with a woman if I fall in
love with a man I fall in love with a
man if I fall in love with a non-binary
person I fall in love with a number any
person right but you know what people in
love do yeah they have sex I know
threesomes wow yeah they do they
definitely do yeah I don't actually want
kids on some friends no if listen to my
explanation
listen to my destination how old are you
oh I'm 19. you're 19. 18 19 yeah okay 18
19. yeah no I'm 19 next month
okay because you can't be two ages at
one no no I know but I'm in my 19th year
that was the first thing that okay okay
you're in a 19 but you're 18. okay yeah
yeah so why don't you but you don't want
kids in the future
I don't I don't like the way this um no
because like that's I just said to you
they didn't lie to me it's because if
you want kids now you're now you're
trying to tell me that I want kids
that's just natural we all that's hard
yeah of course it's our purpose but I
just feel like uh world and like the
environment that I would be raising kids
in I don't really want to raise kids in
this environment climate change all that
climate change yes that's gonna
affect Michael Everyone by the time I
have kids you don't want to have a
family because of climate change yes
well a climate change inflation all
these things like inflation yes okay two
things the climate is always changing
yeah okay yeah I understand that but
like the dollar and the pound has always
inflated okay yeah you're correct
forever it's always it's again the
climate's gonna continue changing and
the dollar and the pound
in its mass like how much it's
increasing and so quickly in a short
period amount of time isn't normal
so what does that have to do with having
kids because I don't want to bring my
even in the sense of like they lie to
you who lied to me they got you this is
this this is the the slave mind this is
the programming I've heard this before
from from woke people they'll say that
they don't want to bring kids into this
world because of but that's not a good
enough reason to not to give up your
purpose but I don't feel like my my only
purpose as a woman is to have kids like
of course that's your highest purpose
yeah of course of course I genuinely
believe that that's
to do to give kids to what
I was manufactured to give kids or
whatever but um I also feel like there's
more to a woman than giving kids well if
you want an equal relationship not fully
equal but I want to have my own so like
if he left me tomorrow if he left me
tomorrow I still have my own if I give
my all to a man and have like nothing
for myself when he leaves what am I left
with
the focus that you should have is on
maintaining the relationship and keeping
that because you want to know the truth
if he's a complete why should I
want to keep that don't pick an
but how do I know until it's too late
sometimes you get into a relationship
that's more important what women your
age should focus on is picking the right
guy that you can have a long-term
relationship with it's not that hard to
let somebody and figure out what their
real character is and also to not pick a
complete loser I think a lot of girls
they focus on their career and being
girl bosses and Q and pride and then
they don't spend enough time investing
into because the truth is guys don't
really leave their girl men don't really
leave relationships it's pretty much
always the girl she's upset about
something she storms off she gets mad
she looks through his phone because he's
cheating but how often do you really
know guys that left that the
relationship is like is going okay and
then he's like he packs his bag and
leaves it's usually the girl but is it
going okay if he's out here seeking
other women
I don't remember her name Aisha
I think it was Aisha she was great she
was I think she's very beautiful and I
would say that was my favorite date so
far I this is maybe it's the mentality
you can roast me the comments but I can
fix her
I could like she's not she's not too far
gone she has like enough of a bubbly
personality she's just been that's the
perfect example of a girl who's been
indoctrinated by wokeness it doesn't
want to have kids because of inflation
what type of what are you talking about
inflation is a reason to not have a
family I will fix her I can change her I
can make her see because she has all the
the right qualities like she's talking
about I'm a queer it's like what I knew
it as soon as I saw the nose ring I'm
like I know you
I can I'm gonna get it out I'm gonna
unplug all the little Uzi vert piercings
and then make her into a wife I can mold
her
I can fix her
I like her
to sing the food because you are hungry
aren't you so let's imagine let's have
an imaginary date what are we eating
right now we're having no spinach steak
steak you're eating you're eating a
whole steak a whole steak
I could eat two steaks really eat a lot
of meat yeah you eat a lot of meat I do
you not eat a lot of meat I mean I
consume a lot of me I don't eat meat
what do you mean you don't eat meat but
you consume it
maybe the terminology the translation
there's probably an error right now but
I understand what you're saying okay
okay so you eat a lot of meat so what do
you do I am a businessman
nice I'm in a lot of different
businesses ah right businesses okay
you're not gonna go into it what do you
want to know nothing really what do you
do
um well I work for a council I put
people into housing if they need housing
like
um usually vulnerable people I put them
into housing I wouldn't move on over
homeless people
um sometimes
um or just people who have like a
massive family and don't have any space
like overcrowding situations for people
that had too much Spanish and the joints
don't work and they need a house
you give them home exactly
are you jabbed no
why not I had a feeling you weren't did
you yeah I think you're saying kind of
coincides with that you want to be a
Trad white traditional wife yeah Farm on
Jabs you know who else is on jab you
I like that song no I'm a Christian
you're a Christian yeah okay Jesus move
away
Muslims we respect Jesus there you go
you know yeah I mean that's fine as long
as you believe in God
because you can't really argue with the
fact there is a God
I don't think so what do you think about
the argument that Jesus is God in
Christianity you see that Jesus is God
at the same time the holy spirit all
this stuff I mean I get that because if
you think about it well you can have
like three droplets of water
and then when you put them all together
they turn into one right so it's not
like an impossible thing for me to think
about I used to kind of find it hard to
get my head around it but
it's not that
um I kind of understand now I don't know
for sure though if I believe that Jesus
is God but I understand that and I I'm
kind of beginning to the more I read the
Bible the more I believe it
um you're pretty smart thanks
um in my spare time I am an activist
so I go on the streets and I talk about
the covered vaccine I talk about
um the new odd order Bill Gates
trying to destroy us
um trying to make us eat fake meat and
bugs what do you think about the world
economic Forum I mean they're planning
on running the world aren't they and
they probably will eventually if we
allow them to
um they're tyrannical they're trying to
make us own nothing and be happy
clouds form
what's your favorite crypto
I didn't use it no so you've seen like a
Bitcoin type yeah one day one day one
day you're waiting I have to learn about
it well you're an activist so where do
you go and do this stuff everywhere on
the tube on the under have you been
attacked by a wokie I've been attacked
by a of two people actually yeah would
they have blue hair no they were they
were actually both old
really yeah do they have a mask on no
actually I think one of them did yeah
one of them did why did they attack you
well actually he attacked my friend he
pulled down her sign and then like
punched her a bit and then she punched
him back and then I ran jumped on him
and he jumped on an old guy yeah because
he was he was hurting his friend yeah
and I was like what the hell but he just
was so angry that he couldn't allow it
to happen but I also went on talk TV
recently where I exposed Bill Gates and
Flash Schwab and I called them
Psychopaths and murderers and I said
that Bill Gates killed thousands of
children which is true because he did
and then they had to cut me off and
they've reported me to like every single
social media and tried to get my account
removed it's very interesting his face
is like hilarious do you like Alex Jones
yeah what do you think about Trump
what do I think about him yeah I think
he's probably the most successful
president that America's ever had great
what do you think about the yay 24
campaign Do You Hear What uh when Kanye
West was running for president I heard
of that yeah yeah what do you think
about what he was saying
um I don't remember what he was saying
but I said I love Hitler oh did he yeah
oh well I don't know what the context
behind that was I don't think it's from
what I've just heard it sounds
a bit weird like I don't I don't think I
would say that personally but it's um
this is birthday today oh Kanye West's
birthday oh yeah I heard about that he
was born on 420. that's quite funny
I just think it's weird that Bill Gates
is buying the most farmland
out of everyone
um why does he want all of that he wants
to control the food that's why we need
to grow on food and have seven kids
completely agree at the same time too
he's saying that eggs are bad for you he
he's trying to be a health expert and
he's just overweight is that a shape
he's saying eggs are bad you're saying
don't even look at him just look at his
face do you really want to take Health
advice from someone who looks like that
okay
[Music]
I'm ready to start a family with her
I was there like another room in here
that we could just I want to get her
pregnant right now
I'm ready I would give her seven kids
everything she says I like and the way
she dressed the way she just
I think she laps up the that I remember
the Wilkie that I was like I'm going to
change her bro what the hell am I
talking about why am I gonna fix a girl
when there's a girl that already makes
sense
and she just
I actually yo let me get her number for
real I don't know so how old are you I'm
24 how old are you
you're 24. yeah
oh my I'm 23. you're one you older than
me why did that you just got so stunned
by that I lit I thought you were like
35. what the
I literally thought you were doing like
way above 35 yeah I look 35
you don't re maybe a little bit it's not
an insult I I like how like I only like
all the guys I only go for them yeah I
can be 35 for you you'll be 35 for me
I'll be 36 for you then
I'll be that'll be 47. maybe 47. I'll be
85 85 . okay
I'll be a grandpa okay anything so what
do you want me to be for you
I just want you to be you I like your
hair I like your personality I like your
honesty I think you're very beautiful
thank you and I think that you will
value the good things that make people
good people because I said I that
cheating isn't the worst thing no no
because well obviously that's part of it
but no it's it's the fact that you value
honesty and truth I really do I could
tell that you're a good-hearted person
and the fact that somebody wasn't good
to you and how much well how that hurt
you in the past but you're over it that
made you that shows that you have a pure
heart which I think is is a valuable
thing to my heart is for IPO and people
take advantage yeah that's what happens
when you're
manipulative people take advantage of
that but it seems like you're so
optimistic which is good it kind of
worries me that you're kind of young
I'm older than older than you and you're
calling me young
women are insane this is why women are
crazy I'm literally older than you and
you're calling me a baby
but you are a baby that was a good one
because
um
I enjoyed the conversation and the the
dialogue some people criticize me for
this type of tactic when I go on dates I
kind of have the this debate style and I
like question girls and they they feel
interrogated I think it makes for
a more interesting conversation because
I get bored just running game all the
time and saying nice things uh I would
not recommend other people like ask
about previous relationships or ask
about her ex-boyfriend but I'm just I've
been on so many dates today I'm just
like trying to keep myself interested
because I know I have a lot more to go
through that was a good conversation
that had me engaged but it's we're not
going to work me and her not gonna work
she called me a baby and I'm older than
her do you see how modern women think
when I was 35 in her head when I said my
age
I went down like five notches in her
head she's like Oh I thought you were
like 35.
oh baby he started patronizing me
started emasculating me because you
don't want your man to be a baby but I'm
literally older than her and I'm a baby
Ken
um
she woke up an hour ago so just through
the song what time is it
so you must have been partying out late
last night yeah I don't even know it
pretty much you party every night yeah
yeah what the club like four times a
week you work at the club are you just
for fun no just for fun
what do you how do you stay up that late
you do
some party favors
um
no I just
do every night because I like it
learning clubs like they always close
really early for my experience it was
hard to find anything that was open yeah
they do kind of but
those bars yeah
what do you why do you like to party so
much
I'm depressed probably
what makes you depressed you're so
smiley I don't know well I just do it
together I don't know
to get my wind off things and just relax
just relax yeah it's a pretty
intense environment loud music alcohol a
bunch of people like touching you
um true but do you like I was a good
club at all really yeah I like a lot of
different types of girls really yeah
I don't know do you like guys that go
clubbing no
I don't think I'd like properly date a
guy was coming
too much
so what do you expect to meet this guy
um
on the street yeah have you been
approached on the street people do that
in London sometimes what do they say
painting
what are you saying
you would respond well if I said what
are you saying fam yeah
[Laughter]
okay
um
drinking the Vodka right now actually
vodka right now yeah you woke up an hour
ago I know
but
you're getting a lot of notifications
already though it's been buzzing
it's like hers it's not my boyfriend
it's just like I don't know
yeah it's not guys I don't know thanks
guys okay so you're at a at a gay club
but it's about to escape it was like a
drag drag party thing and I was like
basically like really weird acts like if
you had a fairies with like bun plugs
and stuff oh so yeah we're just watching
it and we were like okay
again but it was interesting but plugs
and fairies yeah how long were you there
you didn't just leave immediately
no we just stay because we were drunk so
when you're drunk by anywhere is a good
environment to be fair
that's not true I think it's true if I'm
drunk enough anyway it's good you know a
place sucks when you're drunk Church
why'd you attract to a drug off that's
what I'm saying there's a lot of
environments that suck when you're drunk
I mean like clubs like any club is good
enough if you're drunk enough
there's a lot more experiences lots more
feelings and especially you're saying
it's repetitive I do like to travel as
well to Dubai let's go to the clubs oh
no
don't you think that this guy he's got
to be monogamous to you rich over five
ton
do you think that he's going to settle
with the girl who's been partying hard
in Dubai and Spain and going to the club
every night for years
oh 100 he's gonna know I'll just say I
used to spend my time in uni because I'm
in uni so I'll just say I was just a
student just being normal going out
sometimes once in a while so you're
gonna lie to the father of your children
nah I'm just gonna say
like I'll just live with all new
experience which is going out generally
you know
Solas Haram she has that stare that
[Music]
you guys know what stare that is I don't
want to go say it because it's
disrespectful but that was
it's it's sad to see because she's she's
um she's beautiful but
[Music]
yeah that's uh and she said herself
she's depressed and she's gonna keep on
doing what's making her depressed she
woke up an hour ago she's drinking she's
going back to the club tonight she just
came from the club and she's only 19 and
she wants to do six more years of
partying and she getting bored of it how
have you already planned in your head
that that's the next six years of your
life she's gonna spend all her youth
getting by guys in the club
getting flaunted to Dubai in Spain by
random people that she meets and then
settle down when she's 28 it's just like
the mentality a lot of these girls it's
and they say that all the time that it's
just like oh these just Miami girls are
just like that we're in London it's and
I knew exactly the blueprint it's uh
it's a feminism problem it's a it's a
wokeness problem
it's too bad though I would I would
pull it out though
I would I mean I would I would I know I
know I know after Ramadan
yeah I'm ashamed of myself too but I
might even get a number to be honest
I mean she's guaranteed like if we're
gonna go like I'm not gonna be in London
that long you're going to talk about
guarantee like
see this is the best bet if you want to
go like now
let's be honest but Haram
can you explain things that you've heard
that that turned you on in conversation
like oh yeah like because you're saying
that you like when he doesn't like you
you like yeah like bad guys no
you like drug dealers yeah you can say
that so what are you talking about when
you said that you've met you've met
future fathers and your type is the
tracksuit guy with the Gucci purse
mandem with the a machete in his bag
anyway exopolies what is that a dog
I'm not from here I don't even oh all
right so
I you know that that's not is that who
you want to have kids with yeah
okay
you don't have kids with why
don't ask anything that attracts I'm
attracting two right now
I don't like guys of real jobs I just
don't like it
so you'd prefer somebody like
this is going to be the father your
children the likelihood that he goes to
jail is 10 times higher than somebody
who's working regularly yeah but like
when they turn like like 25 then they've
got to get a real job
so you want to date an ex drug dealer
yeah but they can do it like now for now
because obviously they're young but if I
have kids of them and stuff they got
fixed up and get a real job
you don't think that you're going to
become unattracted to him because you
just said you don't like guys with real
jobs I know but it's just for now but I
think when I'm a bit older so you want
to tame a drug dealer yeah
why I don't know I don't know that's
just my mind I don't know it's weird
okay what type of code do you like
I like nice girls I like girls that
I like you yeah I don't know if uh you
already know
you know
yeah you did not help blessing was
behind the camera laughing during the
Imagine we're on a date we're on a date
and you hear laughter at the conversate
and not like because the conversation
was going it was laughing at what her
answers were so I'm just like you kind
of dug me up
I mean yeah that was
[Music]
you must have some crazy Cruise stories
that a lot of people can't relate to
Wild I want to hear the most wild story
oh the most wild story okay so we have
this show oh I say it's a show it's a
game show on board
um that basically you're required to get
into teams and you you have to bring us
different items so we call out Whatever
item it is and they bring it by the end
of it
um it gets as wild as guys have to swap
underwear with people so you have people
in the room with like literally hundreds
of people and people are naked and men
are wearing women's thongs and women are
in the boxes so yeah it definitely gets
wild okay is it like for married couples
who are bored and they're trying to
spice it up it's like a swingers no so
the funny thing is it's not so it's it's
not family friendly it's obviously over
18s but in the sense as you get put into
teens with random people so you might be
in a team with a couple of your family
members but reality you're in a team of
maybe 15 people of strangers and you all
become friends and then you're partnered
up in a team to try and win a bottle of
champagne that's it that is it they do
this all for a bottle of champagne yeah
what do you learn about human nature
from that because it's pretty funny how
you can get men to put on women's thongs
strangers on a random boat in the middle
of the sea and you could die it's
absolutely crazy do you know what bottle
of champagne but it's made it normalized
to me so when I come home and explain
this story to people they're like it's
so crazy but because I see it week in
week out it's like you wouldn't do this
you would do this for a laugh as well
and people were like absolutely not but
yeah it is what do you think it is about
the environment that makes them step out
of their comfort zone like that so
easily
Americans it's Americans we even say
that like in America Americans I'm
telling you Brits wouldn't do it you
bring that you bring that here and you
wouldn't do it you'll have everyone
sitting there like no no no no that's
not for me Americans are willing to come
out their comfort zone a bit more like
you post it on Instagram yeah you get
all these brand deals always yeah wow
and you know I'd never get any brand
deals really I've been doing it for
around 10 years and there's people that
their whole thing is getting that but
yeah you have that good like
presentation personality obviously those
are very presentable thank you you got
the teeth and uh the way your makeup is
and the smile like I could see you look
like you could sell like sell a house I
would buy a car from you oh thank you we
buy any car that could be my next one a
98 Mercedes and it had 120 000 miles and
you presented it the right way you
distracted me with those and I'm looking
down here I'm grabbing the key put it in
the car and I'm out of here I had to
spend 100K on this old car because
because you have that presentation
quality I know I do I do love that I
love I do love that but I feel like you
hold some some of that too I'm not gonna
lie yeah
I can't sell I don't think I could sell
a car as easily maybe I wouldn't be able
to
create the lie to that level I'd be like
this crazy piece of what do you
think about people who don't want to
have kids with somebody who's jabbed
I think that's extra because I don't
think you're gonna like grow or fall for
leg or anything
um from the jab I do feel like there are
other things that it could affect I.E
fertility and stuff like that down the
line which we will never know until it
comes about but um realistically I don't
think it's going to create an alien baby
soon we never know
it very much I mean they just got rid of
that original the original job they
don't they banned it oh I know I know
yeah and we made it what's your what's
your type what type of guys do you
attract what type of guys do you want to
attract okay
um my type has changed so much so a
timeline I I would say somewhere in
between now this I love a man that goes
to the gym so someone that is really fit
got a six-pack good picks that type of
thing but I'm swaying off of that so
much I was obsessed with the bigger the
better before now more so just someone
that takes care of their appearance
someone that is driven
um adventurous spontaneous and caring
someone that's a family goer love people
that is close with their mum and have
siblings around that just know how to
handle kids because obviously we're of
the age of that's going to happen so
yeah
um definitely caring sweet nature about
them what about you what do you like in
a female
I think all those same qualities when I
look for
a partner well not a partner want to
look for a girlfriend I'm looking at
motherly qualities it doesn't really
matter what age it is we had a couple uh
19 year olds come in and they're just
they're gonna keep clubbing for a long
time and they don't really
exude any motherly quality so I don't
think that's worth investing my time
into right now I like a girl who could
provide a spiritual balance yeah I have
a lot of headaches and problems in my
life a lot of people that try to attack
and there's a lot of people that I'm
that I'm up against yeah and I do
approach everything I do with love but
if I don't have that type of balance if
I'm having more problems at home in my
relationship then it's just gonna then
I'm gonna be a wreck and I need to have
that that those nurturing qualities so
what is a red flag with you like
something that a woman just can't have
I think um if she doesn't respect her
father
I think that you could always tell how
they're going to act in relationships
based on how they interact with their
family and if they don't have a good
relationship with their siblings or if
they have a a bad family environment
it's always fighting with them they
speak poorly about them if there's
friction there you're going to see those
same traits in the relationship always
definitely like people just emulate
their parents relationships people
emulate their family that's their method
of loving and of a relationship style so
I think that's a good way to tell how
they're going to act and especially for
women if they don't respect their father
and a lot of time if their father's not
in their life then there are going to be
a lot of issues yeah and you can
definitely train a girl you can mold her
in a sense but you need to have more
experience maturity you need to be much
more masculine you need to be smarter
you need to be better than her in so
many different ways and is that really
worth the guy who's at that point does
he really want to invest his time into
fixing a girl who's 100
uh she's great but I'm exhausted and
this is only like what a 10 minute date
I can't imagine like a release like
let's go camping let's go it's working
let's go whoa canoeing
I mean I'm in here now like already
oh God but yeah good personality great
assets great to look at I wanted to
but
she's a lot of work she's she needs a
lot of entertainment a lot of
energy I don't know if I got that okay
sneako okay how how are your dates how'd
they go it was a great range thank you
Pearl I think hopefully I find some love
and it was a great variety of women
every different kind of girl in one
place different races different ideas
different levels of Haram
and I I mean different levels of Haram
oh there's some there's some these girls
are gone some of them what happened
they're just completely recreational use
only oh oh and they have no intentions
of and even their priorities like it's
just really funny what they're what they
want
and it was just interesting it's fun if
it had all the same different if I had
the same type of girl the whole time
it'd be boring but it's good that
there's how did they differentiate
between London girls versus Miami girls
pretty much the same pretty much pretty
much the same just the accent is
different it's a little bit more
annoying here it's unattractive I don't
like the are you from
like okay but they always criticize
fresh and fit for example for having oh
you just have these Miami girls on I'm
telling you in the west there's there's
not that much variety there's Variety in
terms of like how Haram they are but
their ideology their beliefs pretty much
the same you're going to find the same
girls all over could you have found a
wife today I think so I think so I
picked four and one is waifu material
and I actually am like I'm getting
butterflies just thinking about it oh
yeah
uh so I know this is tough for you it's
not it's not at all I know this is
really hard I know you've grown
emotionally attached to all the girls
here today
um so tell me about your date with uh
Alicia girl in white Haram
so she's completely she is Haram but
she's she's like Recreation like she's
fun you see if I'm gonna pick four yeah
you need to have one of those in the
squad in my opinion okay so I made a
recreation
she's CL she woke up an hour ago from
clubbing last night like who wakes up at
5 p.m and then comes and does a date and
she's drinking now
uh so she's an alcoholic she's 19. she
woke up from the club starts drinking
again and is already planning to go out
tonight Rob like and she has no
intentions to change her lifestyle for
another six years she wants to keep
clubbing until she's 25. so if she wants
to keep on having fun I'll join the
party okay okay
absolutely okay no Aisha nose ring
I like her she's a sweet girl and she's
she's very innocent and I like her I
like her personality she's uh bubbly
she's nice and she I think she's in the
perfect position where she could I don't
want to say need but she could benefit
from somebody who reprograms her a
little bit so that she can have a more
optimistic view of the of the world and
of the future because she's so
kind-hearted that if she's with the
wrong guy like she's gonna she can end
up in the wrong place so I think that if
I were to date her I could uh even if it
doesn't work out I think she'd be in a
better position than without me Jasmine
curly hair
dog recruiter here yeah
um
she just really threw me off uh by she
thought it was 35 and I told her I'm 24
and she went you're a baby and she's 23.
I'm older than her and she thinks I'm a
baby it's just stupid so yeah I mean no
she's not gonna be selected but I think
she understands why like we don't really
you know just let you know no there's no
spark there's no spark and also
butterflies there's no butterflies I
made the mistake too of talking about
her traumatized ex and all I talked we
talked so much about her ex which you
shouldn't I don't recommend anybody
doing a date but I'm just like I've been
on so many today I was just interested
in just trying to make conversation but
I framed it wrong from the jump talked
too much about that it was clearly
making her emotional so it's just you
got way she was emotional about her ex
on the date
oh wow that's a red flag yeah so I can
understand why you wouldn't pick her
yeah no I didn't need to keep on prying
but I'm just like I'm a curious I like
interviewing and quiet I'm like I was
trying to figure people out so yeah
um we also have Jessica you wrote tits
yeah titty was great uh Cruise titties
and I complimented her her boobs during
the
during the date and she was receptive
about it so she seems like fun she's a
little loud
very vibrant like big exuberant
personality which is a bit much for me
she has more personality than me she's
very
but yeah she's you know nice size
um Esther
30.
uh not really you know I kind of bored
her already I mean I mean because we
went on two dates and she's just there
wasn't no spark yeah no spark no spark
but she's pretty though
uh she left earlier your first date oh
yeah she's actually she's nice she's a
really nice girl
um I fake eliminated her I fake
eliminated her earlier in an interview
because
um she was leaving but no she was nice
she made a lot of sense she has wifey
material
comes from a good household and
everything like that she checks a lot of
the boxes yeah I like her Nazarene yeah
I wanna I wanna get her pregnant I think
that would be great for the both of us
so you found love today all right well
hopefully I I don't want to speak too
soon but I I I am in love with her so in
the out of sneako's mouth he found love
on the pregame just pearly thinks the
red kill Bachelor I did I felt I found
my red pill wife so she's more red pill
than me like it's it's really just
I know I thought you guys would get
along I like it a lot so I was I was
begging her to come from work today I'm
gonna ask her out after the show for
real I want to I want to take her out so
so
I know this is tough
um who are your final four
wifey wokey titty and Haram Haram is a
blonde girl her Haram friend can go
um I don't know they're probably gonna
want to leave together so we'll see if
they both leave whatever we can replace
it with a recruiter but yeah titty for
you know nice add variety the wokie
because I see you're good in her and
wifey because she's just a mother of my
children
okay ladies
um please leave yeah if you didn't pick
you you gotta go